hey Vsauce and wacky gamer fans it's
Jeff fragment from nerd wars we're
trying something different this week
we're going over your comments on John
McClane versus Indiana Jones don't
forget to comment on the videos cuz we
may highlight them the next week's nerd
wars straight from our Facebook page
Facebook Mikey gamer comm is Voldemort
from Harry Potter the villain versus
Gandalf from Lord of the Rings but
they're home
so let's get to the comments this was a
good point us can't a fighter
are we talking pre crystal skull Andy or
after during I'm assuming at their prime
I'm gonna say yes definitely at their
prime he goes on to say I'm gonna have
to give it to Indy just barely though
it's if it's both of them fighting
during the fourth movies John McClane
all the way he doesn't seem to lose
anything by the fourth movie in D gets
lame and he does get lame and how much
of that has to do with Harrison Ford
just getting older and being more of a
horrible actor I don't know he was
delivering his lines like he was stone
the whole time hey everybody welcome to
nerd wars today we're doing John McClane
versus Indiana Jones but first we want
to do the call to action for next week
the next arguments gonna be Baltimore
versus Gandalf let us know who you
thinks gonna win Batman but also make
sure to join us on facebook jackie gamer
comm where you sit can suggest the next
next nerd wars alright so the user 70%
of them 70% said John McClane and
they're wrong it's okay
my name is reitman it's cool I'm always
right that's how it works
Indiana Jones is definitely gonna win
this one just Indiana Jones basically
resisted the power of God the Ark of the
Covenant was opened Indiana Jones
basically fought through that stuff
watched Nazis die left and right yeah
I'm out of it okay that's thing he
watched Nazis darling because he's smart
he doesn't need the John McClane fought
the Nazis
and almost beat Barack Obama in the 2008
you're gonna switch it to John McCain
who are we doing John McClane from die
hard oh oh this is gonna be so much
easier John McClane went on dick
Indiana Jones but